A man of many names and just as many faces,
with one characteristic, unsettlingly wide
smile, Doctor Alto Clef has long been one
of the SCP Foundation’s most valuable researchers.
Granted, he also happens to be their most
infamous and would almost take the title of
their strangest member of personnel.
In fact, Clef might be tied for the title
of strangest with one other researcher who
was literally turned into a dog.
But what does an average day look like for
the so-called Ukulele Man?
Surely somebody of Clef’s reputation as
a violent, unpredictable and enigmatic figure
doesn’t just punch the clock at the Foundation
and settle for a boring day filing paperwork.
Well, if you’ve ever wondered what his normal
schedule might look like, then luckily, we’ve
prepared a look at a Day in the Life of Doctor
Alto Clef.
6:00 AM
Rising at an hour most ordinary people would
consider absurdly early, Alto Clef seemingly
begins his day much like the rest of us.
He sits up in bed, gets to his feet and washes
himself thoroughly to prepare for the day
ahead.
In order to make the most effective use of
this time in the morning, despite being up
at the break of dawn, Clef likes to complete
smaller, trivial tasks in regard to his personal
health hygiene.
Although it does little to change the unsettling
aura that follows him around, never let it
be said that Doctor Clef doesn’t take meticulous
care of himself – perhaps even to neurotic
degree.
He’ll begin with exercise, usually trying
to break his record for number of pull ups
and push ups he can complete in a short amount
of time.
If he finds his face is a little puffy first
thing in the morning, he’ll instead don
an ice pack while doing stomach crunches.
His record for those?
A thousand in a row… and counting.
Clef will then follow this up with showering,
using the time under the water to meditate.
It seems odd for someone known for his various
acts of great violence, but even Alto Clef
can take a moment for calm, reflective mediation.
Then, while showering, he moves on to the
application of a deep pore cleansing lotion,
and is particularly fond of his honey almond
body scrub.
Then, exiting and applying a herb-mint face
mask – which he leaves on for ten minutes
as part of his routine – Doctor Clef engages
in his strangest morning activity.
While standing in front of the mirror in his
private quarters, he will just… stare at
himself.
It’s certainly an odd action, especially
spending such a specific allotment of time
doing so.
But even more unusual is how he seems to practice
smiling…
Whenever photographed, Doctor Alto Clef’s
face is always bizarrely replaced with that
of a random animal or object.
Each time, the animal face will be sporting
a wide, almost abnormal grin; the same expression
Clef practices in the mirror each morning.
It is still unknown whether the concealment
of his face to photography is an active or
passive ability Doctor Clef possesses, whether
he does it on purpose or can’t help it.
8:00 AM
Breakfast is usually a meal Clef skips; instead
of cereal or even a healthy piece of fruit,
every morning he’ll sustain himself on more
vitamins than any normal human being would
take in a week.
We do not recommend trying this at home!
Being awake so early affords Doctor Clef the
luxury of a few moments’ downtime before
the beginning of a long working day at the
SCP Foundation.
Part of Alto Clef’s infamous reputation
is he is known to be something of a weapons
enthusiast, and often acts as a go-to executioner
when the Foundation need an anomaly ‘taken
care of’.
As a result, and as it pertains to his job,
during Clef’s morning downtime he familiarises
himself with one of his favorite armament
publications Guns, Guns and Oh Look, More
Guns!
Although how he acquires these magazines and
indeed who actually publishes them is unknown.
Alternatively, he will request SCP Archive
files to be delivered to his quarters so he
can read up on any anomalies the Foundation
has encountered that might have the potential
to be weaponized.
Of course, this is more just a hobby, not
something Clef would actually attempt… unless
asked to.
But speaking of having things delivered to
his room, it is normally around this time
of the morning that a frightened member of
D Class is sent to knock on Doctor Clef’s
door.
Now this too seems rather odd.
The role of D Class is to be expendable, usually
as human test subjects for anomalies, placed
in dangerous situations so as not to cost
the lives of Foundation personnel.
Then, of course, knocking on the door to Alto
Clef’s quarters is potentially a rather
dangerous situation.
It's hard to know for certain if the D Class
sent to hand deliver Doctor Clef’s daily
itinerary will survive the encounter.
Given his renowned unpredictability, it usually
ends up being a fifty-fifty coin toss.
Of course, it does beg the question, why don’t
the Foundation just send Clef an email to
notify him what anomaly he’ll be ‘decommissioning’.
But, then again, being handed a paper itinerary
by a D Class was something that Clef himself
requested.
10:00 AM
By late morning, Alto has normally finished
cleaning up whatever was left of his ill-fated
D Class messenger; unless he was in the mood
to spare them.
Sure, killing them certainly seemed an excessive
practice to engage in, but Clef had seemingly
convinced the Foundation that it was ‘necessary’
for him to function.
It’s obvious that this diabolical doctor
is well aware of his usefulness to the Foundation.
He has long proven himself to be highly proficient
at dispatching dangerous anomalies with ease,
so it’s likely the Foundation fulfills his
bloodthirsty requests thanks to that factor.
After all, they would hardly be likely to
offer up a sacrificial lamb – even a member
of D Class – to anyone else - Well, save
for Dr. Bright’s New Body Quota.
But Doctor Clef has always been capable of
producing results that align with the Foundation’s
objectives, no matter the cost incurred.
Clef has been known to deem any losses, even
the deaths of civilians, to be acceptable
collateral damage in order to kill or contain
anomalies.
And he’s under no illusions that the Foundation
wouldn’t indulge his erratic behavior if
not for his track record.
However, no one in the Foundation knew for
certain if Doctor Clef even needed to start
his day with such gratuitous violence.
As well as being renowned as a killer, Clef
was also a prolific liar.
Were there legitimate reasons for him starting
his day like this?
Or was it all a front, merely done so he could
continue to promote his self-image as the
Foundation’s most ruthless researcher?
The lack of a clear answer was widely considered
to be frustrating to other members of Foundation
personnel.
12:00 PM
Noon, and after a few hours of tending to
his duties as the Department Head for the
Division of Training and Development, Clef
usually takes a prompt lunch break.
Every day, as the clock strikes exactly midday,
on the precise hour of twelve o’clock, Doctor
Alto Clef will stride into the mess hall.
There, a number of Foundation researchers
will normally be gathered, eating lunch and
quietly conversing among themselves.
Popular lunchtime topics of conversation usually
tend to revolve around ways the Foundation
could try to eliminate SCP-682, or what type
of pie is being served in the commissary.
On this particular day, it’s apple pecan,
in case you were wondering.
Naturally, as with many things that Doctor
Clef does, his reasons for taking a trip into
the mess hall aren’t at all the same as
any normal person’s.
That is to say, he doesn’t go there to eat;
or at least, in the conventional sense.
What Alto Clef does, every lunchtime without
fail, is deliberately and methodically pace
his way around the mess hall.
In his hands is his ukulele, the instrument
from which his various monikers have been
derived: Ukulele Man, Agent Ukulele.
Even ‘Alto Clef’ is a nickname; the doctor
has always claimed his real name is an A Major
chord played on a ukulele, making it unpronounceable
to humans.
With his preferred instrument in hand, Clef
will plod between the tables that eating researchers
are sitting at.
Each step he takes is punctuated by the strum
of a note on his ukulele, as he’ll play
a random song painfully slowly as he strides
around.
One lunchtime, it took him an entire two hours
to get through a rendition of Smoke on the
Water note by agonizing note.
Even though it doesn’t seem to be a meal
in the traditional sense – meaning it offers
him no nutritional value – Clef professes
that his midday ritual allows him to feed
on the fear of his fellow researchers.
Seeing him creepily walking around and playing
slow, drawn-out renditions of songs on his
ukulele is occasionally something that intimidates
the newer personnel at the Foundation.
But anyone who has been there for long enough
just finds it annoying; which might be Clef’s
intention, that or simply fuelling his own
ego.
1:30 PM
Usually, by the time an hour and a half have
elapsed from the start of his lunch break,
Alto Clef will reluctantly return to his work.
He’ll often proceed over the course of a
mid-afternoon, to conduct research into the
latest reality warping anomaly he has been
tasked with decommissioning for that day.
It was during one such time of day that he
came up with his plan for the now-infamous
SCP-239 Incident.
An anomalous girl was recovered by the Foundation,
with the ability to alter reality specifically
relating to her or her immediate surroundings.
Doctor Clef viewed SCP-239 as a threat to
security and that the Foundation repeatedly
overestimated its ability to contain reality-altering
entities.
So, Clef proposed a plan involving a sharp
implement made out of SCP-148, a metal that
could block certain anomalous properties.
Clef even volunteers himself to terminate
SCP-239 personally, and would have succeeded
had the Foundation not intervened.
Most of the plans Doctor Alto Clef devised
usually placed emphasis on eliminating anomalies
instead of containing them or making them
safe.
Additionally, his schemes almost always ended
in a large number of deaths, either of disposable
D Class personnel or of civilians.
On this particular day, Doctor Clef has been
tasked with an assignment he found to be particularly
egregious: curing something.
Namely, SCP-451, a former Foundation agent
who suffered an accident with an anomalous
artifact that made him unable to perceive
other people around him.
The agent quickly came to the conclusion that
he was the last surviving person on the planet,
and that he was responsible for wiping out
the human race.
Naturally, Clef’s proposed solution to this
problem was to simply kill SCP-451.
He could still be seen by other Foundation
staff, but nobody could interact with him
directly.
It was as though the artifact had caused a
reality-warping event focused solely on that
one agent, shifting him just outside of reality
itself.
However, after spending hours brainstorming
a way to decommission SCP-451, another researcher
abruptly reminded Doctor Clef that the agent
could no longer be killed.
As a result, in a fit of madness, Clef instead
killed that researcher, before continuing
as if he had been unphased by the information.
4:00 PM
Despite normally having done barely enough
work to justify it, at this point in his day
Clef often likes to treat himself to an additional,
unearned, break.
As with much of his regular flouting of rules,
he often rationalizes the extra time off with
the knowledge that he is apparently untouchable.
Clef knows that there is very little the Foundation
can do to reprimand him, given both his status
as a high-value researcher and his historical
track record for dealing with anomalies.
Simultaneously, he liked to exercise his immunity
to both consequences and the effects of certain
anomalies.
Part of what makes Clef such a valuable asset
to the SCP Foundation is not just his extensive
knowledge of reality-warpers; although he
is considered perhaps the leading expert in
such SCPs.
But Alto has also been known to negate the
anomalous abilities of some SCPs, rendering
him unaffected in the same way ordinary researchers
are.
Much like his fellow long-standing Foundation
scientist Doctor Jack Bright, this has rendered
Clef largely indestructible and unharmable
to a majority of anomalies, allowing him to
continue his tenure at the Foundation for
a considerable time.
As a result of this natural immunity, it is
often during this part of his day that Doctor
Clef likes to pay visits to a former romantic
flame: SCP-173.
Yes, the Sculpture, the concrete and rebar
anomaly capable of moving at impossible speeds
when unobserved.
Doctor Clef and SCP-173 have what you might
call a ‘special bond’, although the Sculpture
seems somewhat indifferent to him given that
it cannot emote.
Clef, however, has been known to be infatuated
with SCP-173, able to view it without being
harmed.
The unlikely couple have even, on a number
of occasions, shared romantic evenings in
each other’s company.
In the dining room of Site-19, listening to
Barry White and enjoying an exquisite meal
prepared by D Class, Clef enjoyed the company
of SCP-173 – the Sculpture wearing a black
dress and blonde wig.
Every week, he looked forward to Friday: their
date night.
7:00 PM
“Okay, let’s see the damage today,”
Doctor Gears sighs.
By this point in the day, one of the last
few orders of business on Doctor Clef’s
itinerary was always his daily, mandatory
reprimand.
Despite there being little punishments that
the Foundation could issue Alto with for both
his annoying and alarming actions, they would
still regularly subject Clef to a list of
his recent rule violations and casualties.
“At the time of 7pm, we’ve logged over
fifty confirmed instances of personnel deaths
on-site,” Doctor Gears reads aloud, rolling
his eyes.
“Only fifty?
I must be having a slow day!”
Clef responds.
“That is, if you’re sure your numbers
are right.”
“Clef, this game of yours doesn’t get
any less tiring,” the other researcher tells
him.
“If you’ve killed anyone else today, please
just cut to the chase and tell me how many.
Oh, and if you think it’s funny to keep
stashing bodies all over the place, then one:
it’s not.
And two: I need to know where those are too.
Oh, and three: just try, for once, for the
sake of my sanity, to tell the truth.”
“Oh, Charlie, you’re no fun!”
Doctor Clef replies with a chuckle.
“This is fun to you?”
Gears asks.
“This?
Right here, right now?
Of course not, you know me better than that!
Look, we both know the reasons that the folks
upstairs get you to sit me down, give me a
scolding.
It’s all a front, just a way to stop any
of those other little researchers getting
any big ideas.
The Council can’t bear the thought of anyone
else trying to do as I do.
There’s only one Doctor Clef, and we both
know there’s nothing anyone in the whole
Foundation can do to stop me having fun.
My numbers are too good.”
“Speaking of your numbers,” Gears ignores
him.
“It says here you’ve received…
four-hundred and twenty complaints about the
ukulele playing.
You want to cut to the chase and tell me how
many of these were filed by you as pranks?”
“Aw, Charlie, you do know me!”
8:00 PM
As very often happens around the time that
most personnel have punched their cards for
the day, Doctor Clef is approached by a trembling
researcher, trying hard to hide the fear on
their face.
While starting as a more intermittent occurrence,
encounters like this have become so frequent
that they have since come to form a regular
part of Clef’s daily routine.
“I’m on to you, Clef!”
the researcher said nervously.
They were the latest in a long, long line
of Foundation staff to confront Doctor Clef
about his supposed ‘true nature’.
Given his violent and unpredictable behavior,
there were rampant rumors that there was more
to him than it first seemed.
“Come on then, kid,” he says.
“I haven’t got all night, let’s hear
what you think you’ve got.”
“You were with the Global Occult Coalition,
before you defected to the Foundation,”
the researcher declared, summoning up more
courage, even if it was a façade.
“You wrote their handbook on reality benders,
but nobody in the world could have that much
knowledge about anomalies like that… unless
they were also one.”
“Ooh, spooky!”
Doctor Clef taunts, inching closer with his
ukulele in one hand.
“The Foundation literally let you get away
with murder, your face can’t be photographed
without changing the image into grinning animals,
you’re-you’re…”
“Go on, you can do it!”
Clef urges.
“You’re an anomaly.
An SCP.
You’ve broken out of containment, and you’re
warping reality to avoid detection!”
the researcher blurts out, adding “You’re
the Devil!”
“Oh, I’m disappointed!”
Clef chortles, finding the theory amusing.
“You almost stuck the landing, why throw
in something so unoriginal?
Let me ask you, do you honestly think you’re
the first?
The only one in the Foundation to ‘connect
all the dots’ and figure out the truth behind
Alto Clef?
You aren’t.
If I was an anomaly… or the Devil, aren’t
I being a little too obvious about it?”
With a clunk of a ukulele against the researcher’s
head, Clef gets one more decommissioning in
before bedtime.
Perhaps there is some truth to what he says,
maybe his power isn't just his immortality
or combat prowess, or immunity to anomalies.
It could be how he’s been able to influence
everyone’s perception of him, even manipulating
the O5 Council into thinking he's too big
of a threat.
His actions have made them believe that Doctor
Clef is better kept on-side as an asset than
to roam free as a dangerous enemy to the Foundation.
That could be what he wants them all to think,
even if it’s not true.
After all, Alto Clef is a notorious liar;
his entire persona could be the ultimate lie.
10:00 PM
After another day of murder and mayhem – mostly
of his own doing – Doctor Alto Clef returns
to his quarters long after the working day
is officially over.
After disposing of the evidence of his latest
‘decommissioning’, he makes his way back
to the room he started the day in, and will
start the next one in too.
But if you think that Clef just gets into
pyjamas, hops into bed, and has a full eight
hours of sleep like a normal person, then
you’d be way, way off.
Firstly, on his way back to his room, Clef
will once again have his ukulele with him,
sinisterly strumming away at the strings so
everyone knows, as they try to sleep in their
own quarters, that he’s still awake.
What’s worse is at this time of night, Alto
intentionally mistunes his instrument, making
it all the more egregious to hear, keeping
the other researchers up until he finally
makes it back to his own quarters.
You might think he would have the sense to
stop there, but he doesn’t, still discordantly
and tunelessly plucking at the strings, usually
until someone dares to gather up the bravery
to complain about the noise.
All of it is to add fuel to the fire of his
reputation, his image as an unhinged, unreasonable
and untrustworthy force.
His behavior is all carefully curated and
performed with the intention to make the rest
of the Foundation believe there is something
off about him.
And why?
Well, if they’re so focused on the strange
things they can see and hear Doctor Clef doing,
it provides a smokescreen that covers up his
true goals, all the dark and twisted things
he is truly capable.
And if killing anomalies and personnel is
his cover, one can only imagine what might
be worse than that.
Much in the same vein, even him retreating
to his quarters at the end of the day is designed
to get in the heads of the rest of the Foundation.
Maybe because Clef really is the Devil, or
a reality-warping SCP.
Or perhaps he just enjoys messing with people,
making them think he’s going to sleep.
Not one of them knows that he’s actually
laying in bed, eyes fixed open as wide as
possible…
with his face locked in that signature grin.
Now go and check out “DR CLEF SCP FOUNDATION
RESEARCHER” and “A DAY IN THE LIFE OF
SCP-049” for more deep dives on Foundation
favorites!